from the director of rush hour three and
x-men three here comes Tower Heist
morning mr. Shaw everything's set for
your dinner party that guy stole from
everyone who works in your building
we're gonna get our money it's all gone
I'm taking a becoming a male prostitute
I think I might have a better idea
terrorize has a huge cast it's Ben
Stiller Eddie Murphy Matthew Broderick
Michael Pena Tali Oni Alan Alda Casey
Affleck every said to be lots of people
in this movie directed by Brett Ratner
and you know as I said my opening he's
made some stinkers but you know he also
made rush hour 1 & 2 and red dragon and
family man films that I think are
legitimately good this film is about a
company of workers who have worked for a
tower this big prestigious hotel Ben
Stiller's a leader of this group of
workers who has supervised and cleaned
have done everything to this for this
tower for a very long time Alan Alda is
the leader of all of these people and
he's lives the top penthouse and he's
rich millionaire he gets sent in trouble
for a security fraud and discovered that
all the pensions the workers had
probably have zero dollars in them now
because of all of this man's crimes and
so Ben Stiller and a couple guys decide
to get together and steal all the money
that this guy has locked away up in his
penthouse are you saying you want to rob
20 million dollars from Arthur Shaw's
penthouse apartment yeah you go to jail
yeah he's gonna guy price lisboa yeah
yes join me I didn't know what to expect
going in Tower Heist because of Brett
Ratner he's made good movies he's made
bad movies he's had a lot of hits and
misses this really is the year of
surprises I'm telling you guys I know I
keep liking everything I see and I don't
you guys to think that I just like
everything but this year has really had
a lot of good movies and this one is one
of them tau rice is actually a really
good movie I laughed quite a bit this is
by far the best Eddie Murphy film I've
seen in a while he is very good here
it's nice to see him doing what he does
best he's not the family Kitty Eddie
Murphy he's Eddie Murphy in this
today I taught you how to pick a lock
with a bobby pin here's your batter Tim
there's your bobby pin there's your
punk-ass Bobby tench you unlock the door
you won't freeze it did ben stiller is
funny in this movie but he's more of
like the George Clooney character of
Ocean's eleven where he's witty and
funny but he's got it together you know
he's got together he's a good leader in
this film and I really felt first
character in regards to what he was
trying to do
there's only scenes with it they weren't
have like a big like yes moment you know
you would think that'd be corny and
maybe a little cheesy but not here I
really liked how they handled here at
red Radner this is one of his better
films in my opinion he made this film
look really nice and even his films that
aren't too good like x-men 3 and rush
hour 3 they all look nice there's
actually a lot of action sequences in
this movie and there's no shakey cam at
all it's all very very nicely shot I
really like that come on restaurant
across from the town what are you doing
supposed to be secret under which
restaurant across you town can't afford
to eat here anyway we can order whatever
we like lunch is on me it's so nice to
see Matthew Broderick doing something
that is just flat-out hilarious again
because haven't seen him in anything
terribly remarkable for a while but him
and Eddie Murphy and Ben Stiller
actually they all have in Michael Pena
and Casey Amma they all have really good
chemistry with each other everyone in
this movie actually works really well
with each other and you can really feel
like the team spirit robbery we have to
be ready to adapt at any moment
how is this bull to be right if you made
out of Legos dimensions are completely
accurate might as well use Lincoln Logs
or tinker toys some of the flaws I had
with the film are basically there are
some character development some things
that are set up of characters and aren't
really ever addressed later or necessary
really does not really much else though
this is a lot of fun I really enjoyed
this film and I'm gonna give Tower Heist
an a-minus I'm not going out there
double blow your face clean off your
face I'm just as surprised as you are
honestly I I don't judge me it's really
witty it's constantly funny there's
actually some really good action and the
heist is fun so I'm going to recommend
if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck my
eyes